here's a friendly piece of advice for
anyone who sees dave chappelle out and
about
don't mention Rick James this decent
chance he'll remind you what the
Fivefinger said to the face
what is the foul fingers side of the
face
what although a short-lived Comedy
Central series Chappelle's Show became
an instant hit and one of the
best-selling TV shows released on DVD
there's plenty about the show that even
the most dedicated fans may not know
here's the untold truth of Chappelle's
Show before the show as a budding actor
and stand-up comedian Dave Chappelle
face plenty of setbacks losing three
times on Star Search and getting booed
off the stage at the Apollo remember
looking out and seeing like everybody
who everybody and his early TV efforts
also flopped the first a 1996 spinoff
from home improvement called buddy's hit
turbulence right out of the gate with
recasting and poor ratings it was
canceled after only a few episodes at
air the next a 1998 show simply called
Dave Chappelle didn't even get that far
after Fox executives want to add white
actors to the all-black cast
Chappelle's walked away expect this my
resignation effective immediately I quit
foreshadowing this really is the Wayne
Brady show no longer the Chappelle show
dave has been downsized just as his
Hollywood career began to gain traction
with roles and movies like The Nutty
Professor and Conair Chappelle met
teenage funny man Neal Brennan Brennan
and Chappelle collaborated on the script
for the stoner cult classic half-baked
but after it tanked at the box office
they parted ways me and Neal after
half-baked when I separate ways we're
good friends but it was just like
leaving a crime scene the Sun how the
show was born Chappelle's Show had an
unlikely inspiration Hugh Hefner's
casual 1960s talk-show playboy after
dark you know we did the show we would
first come up with the format we're like
man why
anyone haven't done a show like this
before he reteamed with Neal Brennan to
develop the new show idea neither had
much experience with sketch comedy but
they learn how to write sketches by
reading books about Saturday Night Live
soon Chappelle and Brennan pitched the
show two networks with mixed results
like we took that pitch to HBO and
Comedy Central HBO looked at us like we
were lepers and then we went to Comedy
Central they approved and and to admit
the pilot one of the two sketch ideas
did sell Comedy Central on the series
was popcopy' which later turned up on
Chappelle's Show
be sure to spray chocolate sauce on the
wall near the toilet to give the
appearance of errant feces this will
ensure that any customer will use our
restroom we'll never ever return to one
of our store Clayton Bigsby the pilot
episode of Chappelle's Show
included what has become one of the most
famous sketches in sketch comedy history
the story of Clayton Bigsby a blind
white supremacist who doesn't know that
he himself is black so we figured we'd
make it easier on Clayton by just
telling him and all the other blind kids
that he was white until either the
custody lady
perhaps the craziest part Clayton Bigsby
was actually based on a real person
Dave's own grandfather it was not only a
mixed racial heritage but also blind
Brennan told vulture that the day Martin
Luther King got shot apparently
Chappelle's grandfather was on a bus at
a bunch of black dudes came up to him
and we're like what do you do it on this
bus cracker and Dave's grandfather
apparently thought and this cracker is
in a lot of trouble before he realized
oh I'm the cracker truth is stranger
than fiction looking night table bilat
Brotherhood
thank y'all for coming by power
he's Rick James sort of Chappelle's
impersonation of R&B legend Rick James
became instantly iconic I'm Rick James
[ __ ]
enjoy yourself but he began hearing the
characters catchphrase is thrown back at
him often during the worst possible
moments it happened during an infamous
stand-up performance just weeks after
the season two finale aired prompting
Chappelle to blast the crowd for their
stupid behavior he considered a stand-up
to be the central element of his career
and told the audience this show is
ruining my life it's almost enough to
wish you were someone else my back
jumping ship
Comedy Central offered Chappelle a
whopping 50 million to make seasons
three and four of Chappelle's Show
he accepted but it wasn't long before he
hit a wall with a sketch about magic
Pixies who encourage people to live up
to racial stereotypes I'll have a fried
chicken thank you fried chicken needs a
new look for this we actually got from a
white crew member made him reconsider
what he was doing
hello differences people laughing with
me and people laughing at me and was the
first time I've ever got to laugh that I
was uncomfortable with Comedy Central
eventually aired the sketch anyway again
Chappelle's wishes along with a
disclaimer and subsequent audience
discussion about the sketches merits you
may or may not have heard Dave said he
had some problems with the pixie sketch
but by that point Chappelle had
infamously quit the show and hopped a
plane to Africa rumors swirled that he
was having a mental breakdown or was on
drugs or abducted by aliens the truth he
just needed to get away from something
that was no longer under his control
don't like having the big for the
spotlight man did you know the Machine
is good for us and we good for the
Machine that it should be should be
failing aftermath Chappelle and
Brennan's friendship was severely
damaged after the show's demise and it
took years to repair what was broken
between them but the two reconnected
years later when Brennan dropped by one
of Chappelle's intimate stand-up shows
although they've agreed to never work
together again they remain friends
Brennan told BuzzFeed
I think there's part of both of us that
holds each other very personally
responsible for our party but another
part of us that sees the whole thing is
very circumstantial more lost sketches
while Comedy Central compiled most of
the completed sketches for season 3 into
The Lost episodes which aired in the
summer of 2006 other unaired sketches
have occasionally popped up on DVD
extras or online bootlegs among them are
sketches like the supersize me parody
maximize me their recurring hip hop news
break segments and an r-rated sequel to
daddy day care starring Charlie Murphy
you asked for it Wow and music fans can
also track down rare performances by
John Legend dead prez and Beastie Boys
among others people feel the beat so
who's that guy doing the robot his
name's Carl Lake and he was a set
dresser for the show
in first season episode Chappelle asked
to appear at a crowd scene and do
something funny
naturally lake did the robot it was so
well received that for the second season
Ryder's made sure to find a place for
Lake to do a repeat performance at some
point in every episode one thing's for
certain if dave chappelle ever brings
his show back we hope he plans to bring
lake with him up let's roll back home
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Chappelle's
Show sketch was your favor